finally this week the president made a
long overdue trip
President Obama focused on the struggles
of Native Americans today he made a
visit to the Standing Rock Sioux
Reservation with his visit today he
becomes only the fourth sitting
president ever to visit an Indian
Reservation that is pretty amazing only
the fourth sitting president to visit
ever I mean technically if you count
naan sitting presidents then antal
Jackson did visit a lot but you really
shouldn't count that but he did he did
visit but you should encounter during
the visit the US Department of Housing
and Urban Development announced they'd
be making 70 million dollars available
to improve tribal housing conditions
including money for mold removal to
which the Native Americans presumably
said ah finally ok we are officially
square it was touch-and-go for a few
centuries there but at the end of the
day all we wanted was our mold removed
[Applause]